it's crazy how we live in a world that's
like a 15-minute news cycle but I think
one of the biggest things that we've
seen lately is all of the drama that's
been going around with Adam 22
um and I think what's interesting as a
whole is not just talking about that
particular situation but I think talking
about the
emergence of sort of these poly or
ethically non-monogamous relationships
in general so I would love to go around
the room in the panel and just get
um a perspective or an opinion on
monogamy versus poly relationships you
know Arguments for arguments against
what you personally feel when you
produces the atom 22
um story like kind of as the example
with this one or yeah sure I can go into
that really quick so adam22 was a
podcaster
um he was a no jumper podcast he married
a woman who did up until very recently
uh only girl on girl sex scenes and and
essentially what happened was for the
first time in her career or life and
after they had been together for seven
years she agreed and he also agreed to
allow her to do a scene with another man
and what was really interesting is that
he took to Twitter and he kind of was
making jokes about it at his own expense
and it was it was really kind of a weird
thing to see at least for me
and a lot of people thought that maybe
it was done because
the no jumper podcast had taken some
heat in recent months and it was kind of
he was a shining star that was kind of
waning and a lot of people saw this as a
way of kind of getting back into that
Spotlight but obviously the internet
really had a field day with this and a
lot of people on one side said hey look
like it's 2023 sex is no big deal people
do it all the time it's just sex it's
not a problem and there's also people
that said I can't imagine ever you know
allowing and condoning my wife or my
woman to have sex with another man so
I'm curious to kind of see where the
panel Falls on
this may be particular issue but kind of
like on the uh monogamy versus
non-monogamy poly sort of stuff as old
maybe let me just phrase the question a
little bit differently uh before we get
to the monogamy versus non-monogamy
stuff uh maybe we'll make that like part
two so I guess the question is here
would you respect a guy
um you know for example like this Adam
22 character if he wanted you to go and
share your body with with another man if
you're in a committed relationship you
claimed him
you wanted to be an LTR or marry him for
example would you respect this guy and
why so let's start with Jessica
so be honest with you I wouldn't respect
them because if he's allowing me to
um use my body on other guys and then he
doesn't like love me the way he's
supposed to be loving me and I wouldn't
appreciate that it could like it's like
the other way around if
I'm not gonna allow my significant other
to be going around and having
relationship with other females and then
coming to me
and kissing me especially with all that
is going around in the world kissing me
um
I believe a lot in energy so like him
doing something with another female and
then that female has that energy and
coming to my house you know I believe
I'm really spiritual so I believe and
I'm gonna respect that all right uh
let's throw it over to Nicole what do
you think about the notion of a guy that
you're in a committed relationship with
says I want you to share your body with
this man
no
um because first of all at that point
I'm being objectified right he has some
sort of like fetish or something that
fantasy he wants fulfilled and he wants
me to be a player in that
um I think I'm no longer
loved fully body and soul as a woman
there's there's a lot of objectification
going on there
um
yeah so no I I wouldn't be with him okay
Shania
uh absolutely not I am definitely a
one-person kind of girl so if the guy
that I was with came up and said hey you
know I think this would be a good idea
to earn money I'd just be like there's
so many other ways why do we have to go
to kind of like what Nicole is saying to
objectifying me and making me share my
body so absolutely not Amber your
thoughts
so
the word allow I don't know how I feel
about that because being someone that is
a content creator that does do own fans
that is very big in the community I'm
very big on expressing yourself doing
what you want but when it comes to
saying a man's allowing you to express
yourself or allowing you to do contact
with someone or him saying you have to
do something with this person I don't
abide by those rules I think they're
it's a little wrong and it crosses a few
boundaries and a few lines and I feel
like that goes completely against the
whole concept but I'll actually wanting
to express yourself on the internet
versus just wanting to get money or
being forced into doing certain things
which I feel like that falls into the
realm of basically
porn I would not want to leave someone
like that okay um I think Shania brought
up an interesting point about money
because
um it seems in hindsight that the reason
why they pulled this stunt is not
because he wanted her to share her body
with another man and he was a [__] and
he wanted to enjoy that sort of aspect
of it but it seems clear at this point
um based on the conversations that I've
heard that they did it for money and for
clout and the amount of money that they
made off it is
um in multiples far far greater than
they ever anticipated
um so they made a lot of money off this
apparently I don't I didn't get any
numbers on it but when you start hearing
you know
certain words getting emphasized like a
lot of money uh it could be a hundred
thousand could be quarter Mill it could
be a million dollars that they made off
this and you only fans you know
subscriptions for their little uh
because they do this podcast where they
interview somebody and then they have a
threesome you know with them afterwards
and then they sell that on the only fan
so I think that was the that was the
driving force does does the idea of
monetary benefit to that extreme like
let's say
a quarter million dollars or a half a
million dollars came out of this stunt
would that change your position on it
no
actually yeah is there a number like is
there a number where you flip that
switch and say okay like I wouldn't do
it for less than this amount
um
I would I would do it if it was with
someone I wanted to do it with but I'm
not gonna have a man tell me oh you have
to do content or make a porn video with
a specific man if it's someone I want to
do it with I'll do it otherwise no
that's my stance on it when it comes to
a man specifically benefiting from
something where I'm advertising myself
absolutely not
that's the whole reason why I run my own
platform
use the word Force somebody brought this
up in the comments
um it's almost like I mean I might be
reading this wrong but it's almost like
um you don't want to be allowed to do
anything it's like you don't want a guy
to own you sort of thing is that
is
I don't want a man to own me the whole
reason I started only fans was because I
wanted my own platform to express myself
I grew I had my own oftv I have a huge
group of friends that we all do
everything together I'm not saying girl
on girl boy and girl stuff but we have a
great community of people I have never
once felt forced into doing anything but
if I had a man specifically bringing me
onto a platform like this Adam 22
character saying okay well now we're
gonna do a threesome and sell the money
and you're going to get
20 of it absolutely not that's so gross
no thank you
so the Tate model is not ideal no in
this situation it sounds like well I I
don't I don't know exactly what like my
guess is if I had to put my own spin on
this like I don't think he and I might
be wrong either might I don't read about
every little thing to that my new detail
but the way I
think this came ahead or came about was
I think she wanted to step out I think
she
wanted to go dip into some strange and
use the cover of it's going to make us a
bunch of money it's going to get us back
on top it's going to reignite our clout
we're going to be back in the mainstream
again because there was a lot of drama
around this guy in his podcast and a lot
of his employees I think were leaving
because of I don't know if it was
mistreatment or there was there's
comments that were made
did you see the short video clip that
she posted on Twitter when she was with
the dude that she was going to do the
scene with she looked very excited
she was enthusiastic about it yeah it's
not like she didn't want to do it or she
was you know shy about it right I and I
don't think that was for the camera I
think that was
um genuine burning desire yes she was
generally burning for that yeah for sure
but I think my next question I think why
this is important I think
we talk about this a lot where you talk
about and Jessica kind of brought this
up where you know if I were to do
something
you know this would happen or my partner
would do something that's kind of like
oh we're on this Eden playing field
we're kind of on this even even level
um
but
can the like can Adam and Elena's
relationship ever be the same is my
question like
she stepped out maybe paid to do so
um made a bunch of money of it but
does this forever change their
relationship and does is this forever
going to be sort of a
stain on their marriage so to speak or
will it not well I mean so I think you
both said that there she was doing
content before like porn correct
but girl on girl girl on girl like it's
all grown girl and they were also doing
this together like they would bring
girls on their podcast together
and there's never with another man
gotcha so and they recently got married
right yes after they were together for
like seven years I think it was yeah
don't they like a seven-year-old
I don't know but they could a daughter
yeah from what I understand I think they
do have a child yeah
um so then you know they've been
together for so long and they just got
married and they've been doing this so I
think their relationship I mean it's
none of my business I don't care but I
think their relationship will basically
be the same because it's always been a
factor in their relationship I mean they
made a career off of it and yeah but you
don't think porn with a woman is
different than a porn with a man you
don't think a woman on a woman having
sex is different than a woman having sex
with a man I mean
porn is porn so like you know even if it
is with another woman it's with someone
else
so you know there was still kind of that
adding someone in there's just something
going on but
I I mean like I said I don't really know
it's none of my business but I think it
just seems like this has been a factor
in their relationship from for a long
time at least he had a bit of bit of a
different opinion Amber can you just
state that again
um honestly I think it's different girl
on girl
it's completely different it's two
different ones
so well if it's just for fetish wise
girl on girl whatever it's hot it's sexy
it's fun turns people on but when it
comes to you sitting there [__] a
random dude to make money it's gonna
gross I'm sorry but it's true unless
it's someone that you're dating and you
like them or you have some arrangement
going on specifically for Content porn
like that sitting around [__] a bunch
of dudes is gross I think it's gross I
don't do that I'm not about it but doing
stuff with a girl is so different I'll
stand by it
with that gotcha I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out